secondly um this is not an example of a
plus-size model this is not an example
of one with a natural body type test
holiday this is a morbidly obese woman
okay for people who are not who are
listening to rationally look at the
picture I mean her blood type is putting
you know Amy Schumer was on the Pirelli
calendar and that's a problem for me
because everyone was saying she was
really brave
now this week was the Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show
so Amy Schumer was nude and semi-nude on
the calendar I actually think Amy
Schumer can be pretty funny it has
nothing to do with Amy Schumer but all
the people saying she's brave and I said
well okay now you have the Victoria's
Secret Show this week no one was ever
praising Audrina Lima as brave what's
the difference ones attractive therefore
it's not brave to be semi-clothed it's
only brave if you're ugly it's only
brave if you're likely fat now people
will say who are you - I've actually had
this famous I guess one of the most
famous plus-size models Tess holiday or
is it holiday I don't know we have her
up on the screen here got pretty mad and
she said who are you who are you to say
what's beautiful the target demographic
I'm the guy who would be buying the
naked lady calendar mechanics men at
work a calendar that has been bought
exclusively by men with naked women on
the calendars a tire company Pirelli
that's who I am here we go who are you
the target demographic is it a fair
enough answer also a man I'm the reason
you would get naked on a calendar to
sell the can't we buy the calendars so a
lot of women so well now we don't care I
got a bunch of naked ladies sending me
pictures giving me the middle finger we
don't care what you think we get
for ourselves no you don't you don't get
naked for yourself and get on a calendar
now in this idea that I'm going to
change society standard of beauty you
don't get to men don't go out like Lena
Dunham men don't go oh wow wow you know
I just thank you I was wrong about ample
bosoms and birthing hips all this time I
want the short of a meal like
snaggletooth butch cutted chain-gang
BuzzFeed looking lesbian who's eating
cake on the crapper that's what I want
I just didn't know it yet that's not how
it works if you want just let me the way
I am okay I will you and your
preferences I was born this way no you
could change yet so Tess Holliday we've
welcomed her in the show one of the
biggest plus-size models I have this up
in front of me she's a large girl now
there's nothing with your big a lot of
men like large women that's fine I
actually think I we've talked about this
I think Adele is very sexy now Adele is
sexy why because she's incredibly
talented she's very pretty
she is a large girl but she's not going
around thrusting herself naked upon
people she's pretty and talented and
dresses nicely and I find her very
attractive I'm married obviously I love
my wife but I'm just saying I find Adele
attractive Tess Holliday not so much she
wrote I came across an article about
some comedian named steven crowder i had
to google it i had to google him of
course there's a little insult where she
said that it she gets mad at me for not
calling you mishima brave it was in
response to Amy Schumer's nude photo
shoot for the Pirelli calendar which was
epic I mean if we're going it depends on
the definition of epic and all I could
think was nope some of us don't do it to
be brave and I can guarantee you none of
us do it for the approval nor do we need
it Steven men like you will never get it
and hell you aren't even original we
have heard it all before and guess what
we aren't going anywhere you might be
rolled somewhere so kiss my fat feminist
bum
after your beauty standards firstly I
kindly decline your request secondly um
this is not an example of a plus-size
model this is not an example of one with
a natural body type test holiday this is
a morbidly obese woman okay for people
who are not who are listening to
rationally look at the picture I mean
her blood type is pudding this is a the
tattoos are designed to cover up your
varicose veins and diabetes spots I
don't even know if diabetes spots exist
after your beauty standards you don't
get to determine my beauty standards and
it's not like we were trying to be mean
the whole point is you don't get to
redetermination fascia Facebook fans
Tess Holliday and you do this because
you want to make a living the only way
you make a living as if people think
you're beautiful you put on makeup you
put on tattoos I don't know who that is
what that tattoo is on I don't know what
the tattoo is on our arm one of them
looks like oh god Miss Piggy
they swear you this girl has a Miss
Piggy tattoo on her arm if I'm missing a
statement well it's a big statement we
didn't choose our biology and you're
something to women this beauty standard
thing they get they get so mad here's
the beauty the male anatomy knows no
prejudice okay you've taken something
that's so beautiful right by appendages
it's a veritable beauty weather stick it
knows no race it knows no social class
it knows no wealth it doesn't care
whether you're big small blonde brunette
either you're attractive or you're not
it's a lie detector test and it can't be
fooled it's as pure as something can
possibly get untainted by political
dollars or corporate influences much
Ronson's a veritable beauty weather
stick you didn't beat the test
Tess holiday and I know I will limit men
out there just no listen we don't lot of
us just don't like fat chicks we like
women who look attractive
you put an unattractive woman on a
calendar we're going to say I'm probably
going to buy that calendar why because
she's an attractive catch holiday you're
fat and unattractive and obviously not
particularly intelligent this wasn't a
well-thought-out post therefore I
wouldn't buy your calendar blood type
pudding latte with Crowder we'll be back
like this video subscribe by clicking my
face or the button above me or one of
these videos next to me it's all free if
you don't like it
I can take off my glasses I can be
whoever you want me to be
ok internet love me I need your
affection what are the latest polls